locke en ville dans l'oise 150 habitants
sans compter aujourd'hui la presse les
curieux et les fans
il était 10h30 et l'on se demandait
encore s'il pourrait arriver devant
monsieur nous le 12 avril 1965 10h30 ont
comparu publiquement devant nous en la
maison commune jean philippe les os mais
militaire drew 43e régiment blindé
d'infanterie de marine
21 ans et qu'il vise georges battant
l'entente artistes 20 ans monsieur
jean-philippe les ospel
concentrez-vous à prendre pour épouse
mademoiselle 6 buts georges martin ici
présents mademoiselle civil en 20 ans
concentrez-vous à prendre pour époux
monsieur jean-philippe les os mais ici
présentes séries au nom de la loi
nous déclarons unis par le mariage
[Applaudissements]
sylvie soyez gentils maintenant vu qu'on
est un peu car nos caméras
d'abord tous nos voeux ta part des
téléspectateurs j'ai compté jusqu'à
maintenant porter vorias jeunesse on
part en espagne parlent en espagne chez
sur wii et on suit et tournait encore
sans drogba sera le prêt ça on n'y pense
pas pour l'instant bon il reste encore à
passer je crois johnny détourné après ça
maintenant pas combien de temps
permission vous a donné à l'armée
quatre jours cattier opus les pertes de
points d'accord et ensuite donc lalla
qui ses cordes qu'au mois d'août au mois
d'août vous ferez des tournées avec
sylvie tout de suite après vous partez
seul avec soulevé je ne pense pas parce
qu'elle a son métier à faire de son côté
est moins bien tout cas j'ai commencé
mon métier retrouvé l'armé d'accord
merci de génériques alors tous nos voeux
un de la part d'eads et merci encore il
leur a fallu 20 minutes pour gagner
l'équipe
nous avons réussi à les accompagner pour
vous montrer en fin de compte un jeune
couple comme les autres
[Musique]
jean philippe smet
vous déclarez vous prenez maintenant si
lui tape temps ici présent votre femme
est légitime épouse selon avec l'autre
mais là sans titre wii vous promettez
des mig erwin évident qu'une chose comme
en finale ils ont le droit à son épouse
selon le commandement de dieu si divers
temps vous déclarez vous prenez
maintenant jean philippe smet ici
présents pour voter ou illégitime
votre mari est destiné selon le rythme
ternaire la sainte église
donc on était navigable finalité en
quelque chose
tony fidèle épouse le doit à son époux
selon le commandement de dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous unit un mariage au nom du père
du fils et du saint-esprit mots et
maintenant nous allons élire les
alliances l'alliance cette image
merveilleuse de métal pur sans mélange
la metal solides qui lient et qui suit
bien et je souhaite que cette alliance
des panneaux restent toujours faire nous
et qu'il faut jamais oublier france
football
avis que nous sommes forts le ciel et la
terre qui a fait le sel de la terre
saignait a exaucé nos prières qu'elle
arrive jusqu'à votre seigneur bénissez
cet anneau une pétition de votre part
afin que celle qui la porte à la garde
toujours à sonner tout une fidélité
inviolable qui elles vivent en paix
comme vous le voulez et que tous deux
ont tenu à s'aimer mutuellement toujours
à pied du christ notre seigneur
amen
ça
[Musique]
m